[Music]
welcome back to off the record we're
talking about whatever
we want [ __ ] and uh what's new with
you anthony we got anthony back today
what is what's new
i joined the kenjus hey can you present
i finally tried your noodles too that
[ __ ] was pretty bomb it's delicious it
took me
six months to try it but i finally tried
it did you like it yeah i liked it yeah
yeah yeah
i was on a diet so i couldn't so it's
just been like what are they called
shrimp ginger bananas
yeah they're actually [ __ ] where can
i get at amazon
wait where's the box we have one here
did someone take it home
of course it was casey tiff loves that
stuff he makes us take it home every
time i got a growing 13 year old boy
like
all he wants to eat is like instant
noodles and kimchi bang noodles but
between the two i'm like ginger bang
vegan right my lunch my lunch in junior
high
every day was literally like the chicken
flavor instant noodles or the shrimp one
and then hot pockets with flamin hot
cheetos stuffed
you know how to eat like a [ __ ] eat
that that's for real
like two years straight like how do you
how do you
are you like in a lab trying to figure
out how to like what what kind of taste
you like because i love kenji bang
yeah yeah the first time definitely um
there's like uh
you know um our partner had like uh
contracted a
mission star rated chef to like kind of
work on a lot of his other food
products and stuff like that and then
when we got into the lab we were just
tasting different flavors based off of
like you know manufacturing
a manufacturer in taiwan and stuff like
that you know really just kind of
tasting different flavors that would
make sense
at the end of the day we wanted the
spicy one so they're spicy noodles but
you know for like asians
it's not really spicy it's not spicy
it's not it's got a it's got a bit of a
cake it's not spicy yeah
but but for like america or like middle
america it's like
that's considered spicy well it's
considered spicy you gotta put spicy on
it exotic spices
from the east well we're really we're
really excited about like future stuff
with it you know what i mean um
having a non-spicy version so to speak
come out
having a different noodle cuts that are
about to come out different flavors and
stuff that's all kind of like in the
pipeline right now
plus a lot of like uh um
i'm trying to find the legal way to talk
about this stuff cause you have
ndas for this stuff yeah absolutely yeah
i'm excited we're learning the secrets
really really cool and exciting things
that are about to happen i can't wait to
make an announcement here when i'm
allowed to
oh does it have something to do with
like the dynamite extra hot noodles and
[ __ ]
nah nah it has it has uh stuff to do
with things like
licensing distribution oh [ __ ]
those that's like sexy words that i
don't even know what it means but i know
it sounds like
for investors
those eyes are very exciting i thought
your eyes just laid i'm sure you're like
it's like i'm looking for investors the
answer is always
is it turning a good conversation
we gotta always have a good conversation
and best conversations always happen
over alcohol
actually the idea of kindred bank
noodles came when we uh we
had a good amount of drinks uh when when
me and mike were
catching up with our boy alex and we
just were
you know it would have been like 10
years since like we we've known each
other you know all of us went our
separate ways for like a lot of business
stuff we finally came back together
doing this reunion and then we just kept
on pounding drinks
all around arts district and next thing
you know we're talking about different
ideas and
there was just this like huge aha moment
where it's like
me and mike always argue about like
what's better like ramen or fuzz so we
just like randomly
like noodle thing you know what i mean
um and obviously he makes like
plant-based stuff that's like mainly
like all of his stuff's like plant-based
right my mike's vegans
alex yeah why is he is he vegan
vegetarian or he's not but
uh it's it's um it's making the
disruptive market sexy right that's kind
of like at the end of the day like
usually what you you kind of need to go
through with
especially in the food market nowadays
right yeah um always trying to find a
more
healthy way but still making it sexy to
the mass public right um and then we
just like went into this whole kind of
like
perfect storm of conversation with
drinks and then next thing you know it's
just like
we should make plant-based noodles and
literally all of us were [ __ ]
then we took another shot after us
because it was a great idea and then
next thing you know we got noodles i
like how you guys didn't consider making
ramen or pho
yeah i've been awesome disruptive right
noodles are those i never had
actually so so the fact that they're
soupless noodles yeah right which is why
you know when you make them yeah the dry
noodles you gotta like you know and and
also creating the tray
in an innovative way so that you can
like microwave it and be able to pour
yeah using the lid like that i'm sorry
that's not the first time i've had
something like that
yeah but it's the best one yeah that's
pretty good no but the type of noodles i
don't i didn't
i never had that kind before like i
don't know what culture it is or what a
[ __ ] internet commenter thing to say
i know
i've done that before i've seen this
elsewhere i just had to do it to him
did it was it weird for you guys to go
like but we had like a dance brand to
go into noodles like was it like or did
it make sense or like
you know that's a great question no no
that that is a good question
um i actually just answered this so for
an interview the other day because
people are always like
how and why right and i think that we
were so in the project yeah
that like it made sense to us in a way
that like anybody who would be like what
the [ __ ] is kenji's doing making like
noodles right
yeah um but like i said perfect storm
the coronavirus [ __ ] us up so hard
right like
everything that we were doing before was
traveling around the world and teaching
or performing
live events for corporate gigs or like
huge arenas um
you know uh dance competitions and like
giant shows
so you felt the same pain of
[Laughter]
in dance studios like people remember
how dance studios and gyms were the last
tier that could open back up into the
cd2 so we were like
literally at the bottom of the totem
pole stuff
and there was just this like defining
but also like really difficult moment to
accept like
yo uh we're a fully expendable business
and industry and we're not essential by
any means
you know what i mean once you recognize
the entire world that you've dedicated
your life to and built
is like kind of non-essential the second
something like greater than
the world comes like a global pandemic
which could happen again
in any number of ways you know what i
mean it's kind of like you you start
reassessing and one of the first
it was more of a basic instinct like
kind of like what can we do that's way
more essential
like how do you pivot hard exactly so
you know when we thought about the food
industry
remember that at the beginning of the
pandemic like it didn't matter it was
shitty food everything was off the
shelves except for the healthy
stuff that was still there except for
the plant-based noodles
yeah anything vegan still on the show
brown rice
fully stocked no one's touching brown
rice bro but that's because you got to
make it
sexy which is also why even the
packaging for us we want to make it look
like a
[ __ ] sneaker drop you know what i'm
saying yeah i like that we had to make
it a certain way so that people
um and you know i think also the game
plan
wasn't necessarily about like volume in
the beginning it's like about
like uh success of the noise you know
what i mean and making sure that it's
going to make some sort of dent in the
not necessarily in the wider industry
but for people to even change their
perception of what kindred is
to think that we're just like a dance
studio or a dance team or whatever
to now think like wait a minute they
could do more than this
that that in and of itself was like very
very important for us to like
transcend that line it made sense to me
because i was like after i
started um dancing and i was finished
with my robot i was like
i'm hungry man i wish i had noodles i
know
and i'm like thank goodness
you know it's like powerade but like for
for you know
kenz it was it easy to get that on
amazon or is that is that a big [ __ ]
anybody can kind of get anything on
amazon right in essence
they take a ton of money though yeah
they do take a a
they take all your profits but but to
get something validated on amazon and
put it um on like amazon prime
that's a totally different beast enough
you got to go like amazon university
you know what i mean to learn the inner
workings of the entire thing um
and then also with the food products
specifically too there's so many like
restrictions especially from an
international point of view as well so
like getting it
and having only available in amazon us
was its own endeavor you know and like
not available to the world so
um and then also they amazon's [ __ ]
amazon
like they don't need anybody yeah right
you know what i mean so to
you have to prove your worth and walking
into the office where the guys already
[ __ ] you
what do you want exactly like we don't
need you
can i please sell this zooming mug for
no profit because i want your exposure
that's basically how it is especially
the way that especially the way that
amazon prime works because if you want
something primable then you need to have
your inventory in their uh warehouses
and stuff like that if you ship things
and do fulfillment on your own
then it's not prime so that's why
amazon's like cool do whatever the [ __ ]
you want yeah
right but if you wanted to have like
that prime which is that credible and
also that quicker search kind of feature
to be at the top hit
like you need to have your inventory in
their warehouse but
for their warehouse like they they have
so much
real estate in all their warehouses in
the different regions so for them to
even [ __ ] give you like
space for like a pallet you know what
i'm saying it's like you got to get a
lot of balls yeah you better you better
be [ __ ]
killing it you know because they have so
much leverage and power so it's like
that whole game in and of itself was it
was a dope learning experience and
you know i'm happy to say that we did
well that's tight man that's tight dude
and doing food stuff obviously you got
all kinds of regulations to deal with
like that must be
crazy today's video is brought to you by
audible
okay i used to be a book worm
but recently i switched to all audio
books
and when i mean recently it's been the
past two years why you do that for
well because one um books take
me like a full attention like my eyes
have to be engaged and whatever right
but sometimes i i think i retain maybe
i'm an audio
like learner but i retain things better
when i can hear it and someone's telling
me something so like and also i can
double task like i can multitask
wash dishes i can be working out i can
be doing other
things while i listen to a book and with
my busy lifestyle i think that it's much
um easier to actually get the book done
that way
versus having time scheduled to sit down
and read
yeah i used to read and drive and then i
crashed and it's like
no just kidding you're all like i'm like
hey i'm on chapter five okay wait for me
no but audiobooks for me it's like i can
listen in the car cuz that's not the
time to just chill i think i'm like you
were like
if i read i don't know if it's like my
add or something sometimes i read the
same sentence 20 times and i don't even
get it
yeah but i never have to re-listen if
i'm getting attention
yeah it just goes in my ear and i go oh
so that's what they said much more
engaging
yeah but i've been on this audiobook um
dale carnegie's how to win friends and
influence people and i i think i was put
onto it because
warren buffett the second richest person
in the world or whatever they asked him
like if there was one book
that you would uh invite someone to read
which one would it be and he said it's
that one because
what how he contributes his wealth is to
picking great people in his team and
also like breaking deals and being able
to like
be socially intelligent so i was like
that's pretty awesome so let me check
this out
and i do really like it because i think
it's improving my friendships and
relationships so yeah i think that
audible is the way to go
if you want to learn certain things
audiobooks is the way
yeah and also they have audible plus
which is a place that has
music podcasts pretty much everything
for all your listening pleasures
so go check it out audible.com off the
record
or you can text off the record to
500-500 so to sign up go to audible.com
off the record it is crazy but
thankfully for
the kindred side of stuff me and mike um
worry more so about like the marketing
and luckily our specialized
you know producer of a partner uh who
has been doing other food products
understands the learning curve of the
entire regulation and
and all that stuff you know specialized
i don't like which is important right i
think that's the beauty of like
where we've at least like allowed
ourselves to recognize that
maybe through dance we've been able to
build up you know
uh a following of influence
so we've kind of just turned our dance
team into more of like a
marketing machine and then insert
product
shout outs to your guys's branding
though because you guys crushed it in a
way where
it didn't seem weird you know i think
like like one of the greatest brands
apple
for them to focus only on computers and
then all this and drop a phone and
you're like
oh that's tight i can get behind that
versus like if hp dropped the phone i'm
like oh
i don't want to [ __ ] hp phone but for
you guys to like
be in dance and then also create
something that's just as branded and it
just kind of made sense like i didn't
really need an explanation i never
needed to go
why is anthony doing them oh those
noodles are tight that's dope
because i think they looked really good
too yeah like they looked really good i
knew it was on point
i'm sure a lot of people like it they
taste really good too you know so
i gotta get you one so you could taste
it yeah they're bomb i need to
i need to try some but also too is like
with the apple stuff it's like if apple
did
if they came out with the phone and they
only made computers and the phone
[ __ ] sucked dick like no one's gonna
buy that off
but the fact that you guys made some
noodles and it it's [ __ ] really good
and everyone likes it
and it's really aesthetically pleasing
then yeah then it's
so good that that i took a long time to
open the package
yeah you don't even want to open it you
don't want to rip up the the [ __ ]
artwork
yeah because the design's so on point
that you just want to display it
on the box too when you look at your
relationship is dope yep
and we love anthony let's talk about how
handsome anthony [ __ ]
really i really enjoyed this video
can i upload this on my youtube can i
give you a business idea
i think in the packet or in the noodles
you should put things that expire really
quickly
so if they don't eat it within a week it
goes moldy egg
you gotta find another one
just just no down the shelf life
he's gonna [ __ ] up his margin so bad buy
it now and if you don't eat it hey
you're [ __ ] up dude
i will say considering it is a uh you
know uh
air dried and never fried product which
is why we legally
uh shouldn't call it instant noodles oh
because instant noodles technically
is like already cooked which is why the
shelf life on those things can last
[ __ ] forever and people just eat
or remember as a kid you would eat it
and not even cook it you just like
crunch it up
exactly you can't do that with our
noodles because they're air dried so
technically they're raw noodles which
also
is what makes them so fresh when you eat
them oh they're healthier that's also
why they're like
you can get them all al dente and stuff
like that what's the shelf life on them
it's still like a solid year which is
like that's a long time yeah which is
like longer than like most
you know other plant-based products out
there so it's almost like pasta then
right like pasta technically it's raw
noodles you have to cook it exactly you
got to cook it in order to eat it
yeah i've eaten pasta without cooking it
it's good i uh i don't recommend it
and it gets stuck in your teeth like
nothing else that's ever been created
by man why did you eat raw pasta i
remember
you were just being a kid and being
hungry as [ __ ] and then you don't want
to do anything what did you do grab a
[ __ ] bunch of gold
exactly i ate a whole stick of noodles
that way when i was a kid stupid [ __ ]
i like your situation with amazon
because uh
i don't think this will happen to you
but amazon approached us to carry our
supplements on amazon
but seeing like their trend how they
carry something and immediately they do
the amazon basics of it
they steal it yeah so they steal it they
immediately give a much cheaper more
generic version and they just wipe you
out and with supplements
that's really easy to do like vitamin c
is vitamin c right across
200 brands so far less is the barbell
brigade version
even with ours do we put like
proprietary [ __ ] in it but still they
can just look at it like he's just
trying to help you out man
same ass [ __ ] now i know what you guys
do with it bart hates business it's the
same [ __ ] we do have cool formulations
but honestly it's the same [ __ ]
and so for them we're like it's true we
wanted to but i'm like dude i don't know
i don't know if we can just
immediately get wiped out that way but i
think your guys is so custom and it's
also like a very cultural noodle i don't
i don't even know what culture it's from
it's it's perfect fake
asian one that you guys created he won't
he won't answer it too he's like yeah
the kinja's world is like the [ __ ]
airbender avatar world it's like
yes you guys created all these things
and it's almost like i came into a pf
changs and i don't i'm like what asian
is this
i have no idea but then i'm there and
i'm like this is the greatest asian food
i've ever had
okay can we get more of this please so
even the noodles come out that way
because i'm like i don't know what this
is
i never ate this before i bet you is it
chocolate when the camera is off and i
tell you what it is you're gonna be like
oh because there's a similar noodle like
in
the in a japanese instant noodle one
it's kind of like yakisoba
and then you make it the same way too
you kind of like drain it and then
mix it but it doesn't taste like that
yeah
doesn't it taste like that at all man
that tastes [ __ ] good yeah oh my i
gotta get some
noodles now yakisoba look out watch out
yeah
watch out and they're like okay cool
we're literally suing him into hell
like we're a billion dollar company [ __ ]
him
we have a patent on that do you have any
plans for any other foods or anything
like that
like chips i think i think first we
gotta um
like really kind of ride this one to the
wheels fall off and like really learn
especially for like uh the kinder side
of stuff really like learning
how to because even like figuring out
how to market food yeah
it's different you know as a og kind of
like dance crew is like a
that in and of itself is like a really
really interesting and really fun
adventure but
you should see all the commercials that
we don't post and like oh
you know what i'm saying because like
from uh from the professional company
point of view which is why you'll see on
like our
kinder bang ig and stuff like that we
still have to make it look like a
a corporate food company you know what i
mean
that like people can trust and
understand and whatnot from our side of
things we like to do marketing
if you think about kendra's doing
commercials for noodles
there's no [ __ ] way we're gonna take
ourselves too seriously like everything
we do is a joke and it's ridiculous
please try one where you take it really
seriously though
that shit's so funny we had i mean we
had one of our like
operations directors too she comes in uh
and we needed her to be the hand model
to do the amazon video in order to like
do the noodles the right way
you know when you put in the microwave
to show the directions that was the most
serious one we ever did and it took us
forever because we were trying to do it
all like legit
it's hard to do seriously yeah super
hard afterwards we're like nah we're
just going to just troll everything
and those are the ones that get like way
more views right you were like oh what
is this noodle thing people love that
[ __ ]
is there anybody in the crew who's like
dude i just missed when we used to dance
man
the purists man there always is
it's it's more like you know uh for we
like to say
kenji's is what you make it you know
what i mean so it's like if
you you want to take care that's too
much power for your team man you gotta
[ __ ]
dictate that [ __ ] sometimes sometimes
that's just how it works
out and but if i signed up to be a
dancer with you guys and i find out
we're doing noodles like what the [ __ ]
is going on
if you don't see that and think to
yourself i signed up for the right dance
group
then you you don't belong
i miss how it used to be when we used to
just dance and get together and
move and it's like but you enjoy being
broke i don't care about money
there's people like that straight up
they just want to [ __ ] be a bum
and they don't care about building the
family or nothing else
and they're like for the rest of my life
i just want to do the thing that i
signed up for
hey to be fair i think we're still
killing on the dance side so
i think you guys are too but like you
said it's not like you do a zoom dance
thing when
if everything's shut down like we we did
it's just like
not again super lucrative and it's like
you know and and
you don't really get to connect with
your students you know what i mean
you're not like sitting there like
really getting a chance to work
imagine like teaching like a fight
lesson i did that over zoom a couple
times and that [ __ ] was rough
but it has to be right because all you
want [ __ ] them up
one night i can't physically punch you
through the screen now it's like
you wanna like you gotta feel you gotta
like physically yeah you gotta be with
your your student a little bit so it's
like
you wanna have that that physical
interaction because it tells you a lot
more than just watching somebody and
then you feel like
i feel bad for taking some people's
money because for you know you're
watching somebody on zoom and you're
telling them what to do and you're like
all right well
okay at that point yeah and if there's
no like
like zoom is cool but there's no
physical there's no connection i've seen
some instructors like hold pads
and then the students on the other side
look that's cool they're just doing what
they can yeah like they're holding pads
on this side of the screen
hook whatever everyone's wasting each
other's time yeah and then there's
people that are still
finding ways to train i guess oculus and
stuff it's like
we'll see virtual reality have you have
you done boxing on the oculus
no i want to play it really talk about
like actually
it being legit really it's legit does it
vibrate when you get hit or something
nah but like it flashes
just like knocked out the feedback of
you punching
and then them hitting you right back and
like it's it's actually really dope you
get a [ __ ] workout out of it
you get a [ __ ] workout bro and by the
time you you're knocking this dude out
you're like you're so tired like you're
sweating bro like it feels like a real
[ __ ] fight
you ever tried it like do the oculus for
the boxing that's way better than doing
a zoom session with me
do you see your hands dude yeah yeah we
both do
are the hands like super shaky and like
all [ __ ] weird tracking
not not the game that i played no no not
that one what was that old old nintendo
game
the [ __ ] punch out my favorite mike
tyson's
punch with max so dope and then you
gotta [ __ ]
rub his shoulder to get a little bit of
energy back
you